Podcast that Shepherd did a podcast with
Rob McElhenney and the dude who's on the
Marvel they meet the first Indian coming
out tomorrow
Kumail Nanjiani oh yeah so those three
dinner podcasts just on men's body
insecurities and lifting weights and
it's fantastic Wow ITEX Rob I went
because they're Tama how much Dax are my
how he loves to see a good package
flopping around so I sit Rob the video
of me and Rogan we're talking I they got
around the forty and his dick flopping
out that way here's the greatest dick
flap you over see in the hips right and
that guy when you run you and I know
that your dick turtles up your dick is
like I'm going into my this guy was
running full speed and his dick floppy
flop I mean it was like a lot but like
rabbit ears it's a great podcast is that
that this is a well-built kid yeah cuz
they day I'll talk about the
insecurities of their bodies and how
they feel fat even went and rob was
saying how you know on when he did It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia in
Philadelphia he did bolt so he did one
spectrum we got really fat for a role
that he brought he's the writer right so
he wrote that he got really fat so just
eat whatever you want to get super fat
which is hilarious and then he did
another one we get super I've seeded on
his chat bring up the rhyme Rob look at
he's got a great body
oh dude he got jacked but he was various
I mean that's crazy muscular but he was
saying how how into thinks he got he's a
special dude I don't know but he's
talking I got really special dude you
want about talent writing directing God
think that's all I miss you know II
Sonny know I've never seen the show he's
from Philadelphia wrote the show look at
his body it's ridiculous why wouldn't
you always look like that well it's -
exactly I always look like that you
can't entertain that right yeah but he's
saying how he's waking up me is
dedicated and but what are you saying I
can't say this that in the baby he looks
phenomenal
he looks like [ __ ] Armor sword he
looks like John Clubman yeah now now was
that gonna help her
that's the only reason I didn't like the
pockets they don't talk about steroids
at all and I didn't appreciate it
because specially kymaro where the [ __ ]
is name the mail definitely steroids and
come on Rob you definitely took some
[ __ ] sure but what I read on bring you
know
I don't know now daddy might go on that
stuff we've been talking about this you
just do I won't do it I wish you would I
know maybe I'll try and convince Jay to
do it can't the lids get my listen can
he be ridiculously huge ace so way too
big Jay's got a great body he'll be
stupid you fought in the UFC do we have
to hash my athletic achievement you
fought in the UFC
yeah that's Henry's 10 years have you
crazy
I watched a little bit a little bit of
it the other day it's too much no I mean
I understand how it can make people
excited yeah yeah but like and I
understand how you could think that that
that there's a it's important yeah I
feel like you're searching bro thank you
anyhow you can see how some people could
see how that like that it's really
important but no I couldn't say letter
why don't you know there's a lot energy
going and I'll run in there I watch any
sports no mark I don't man and it's
really not because I have anything
against sports I don't have the my
attention span I want to get to the
let's win already do you know what I'm I
don't have a lot of patience
that's better do you know what I mean
like it I imagine if I let myself
something like UFC would probably be
pretty good for me because each round
you know something someone's going down
but then the problem with that stuff is
if like if both of them end up standing
you know gives a [ __ ] like you don't
mean like you could invest in our and
it's like no one went down
what did what I just do yeah you know so
you know I don't in baseball's too long
football's I don't know it takes so it
everything takes too long you're well
the only guys you and Chris D'Elia are
the only two I know that don't whatever
watch any sports
daliyah's like it doesn't matter yeah a
friend of mine when I was working here
no Frank Santorelli from Boston now meet
him when I did short attention span on
Comedy Central he was sort of he was on
the show of me he's my sidekick in a way
and he was all excited about Super Bowl
II so he even watched I'm like no I
don't watch any sports I don't want you
football he goes he just looked at me
like complete earnestness and goes then
then how do you feel alive like you know
he could it's just way they grow up in a
certain light culture that
it's communal right so that's communal
it's competitive
oh that's a great guy oh he's great
funny [ __ ] dude he is funny yeah
great guy yeah but yeah I mean I played
a little when I was younger you know
minor weeks though you're starting day
okay again a ball streets of Albuquerque
yeah streets Albuquerque no I did did
some Little League did some swimming
when I was younger went back it was
actually it stitches in Boston
you know it's back around the time it
was before you started before you knew
me I must be 1988 or 89 it was back
around when Rogan started I remember
when Rogan started it was that that era
and I was like doing my kind of
aggressive confrontational I remember
doing this whole set and some dude just
walks up to me he goes why comedy those
are important moments in your life
they're important mommy I had to take
him in like what else is like oh and
then one time Carrie Hoffman came up to
me years after that when I was working
hello Carolyn was the owner of Stan of
New York the original owner of Stanley
very famous Club and honored manage
people and anyone on to become a Sinatra
and Jose he did a great Sinatra
impersonation he so good that my father
who loves Sinatra offered to finance his
first album and then my father bailed on
that because he was probably so funny
came from the picture of him they've
Kerry Hoffman I very much areas that
mother [ __ ] always liked him though
Wow he was alright he was nice enough
but he was sort of like you know he had
this at it like aah get him off you know
he I don't know he came up to me I
they always stuck me on shitty spots cuz
he didn't like what I did really but he
knew I was doing something yeah and he
couldn't stop me that was the problem
these [ __ ] gatekeepers and in general
July I know it's just that like you know
club owners you know if you didn't play
the game
whatever game they were playing you know
they had a lot of power over field yeah
and you know a lot of them were [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah but but he used to give me
bad spots on showcases for Letterman and
[ __ ] but like one time he came up to me
he goes he just said this to my face he
goes you know your comedy isn't about
what you're doing
anymore I'm like what look at what do I
even do with a good carry embers I can
do an impression in case we if I don't
think about it too much
yeah but uh I be able to do it I've been
working on a George he's got to get I
think Harry had a good high parked my
car out in the lot
it's my George see sky it's a good Marc
Maron doing Jersey Scott clothes I'm
closer is that Brolin right there on the
right yeah what look at that dude well
did you see you saw him as a cable see
now like Alan when you look at that
what's your first thought ah
I mean I can get there right no I take
that guy that's a strong thick dude that
that'd be a tough guy to fight in an
elevator yeah it's cry stairs it's a
beautiful whiskey you don't drink it out
of its disrespect long to crack it
hammered that's fantastic isn't that
beautiful
what would you say about the bottle
please don't wring it out the bottle
Pappas that's what I do do hey smooth
Jack streets out of a bottle smooth jack
drinks it out of a bottle jacks and
smooth drinks out of the bottle is that
true
wow that's impressive God your whiskey
company should be called Jackson smooth
but how the [ __ ] do you compete with
that
mm-hmm cat was actually there and heard
the plant in San Diego you thinking
about starting your own whiskey Toyota
it's always something in it I'm too into
whiskey why wouldn't I I'm too into it
why wouldn't I do dude maybe they could
do like a Last Samurai whiskey you know
Tom Cruise is like the last white white
samurai yeah I could do that for Bushido
its game yeah what's this I was just
watching the noisy on post Malone yep so
this was submitted by Jay Brock - 955 on
instagram with the arrogance gremlins
you can't follow you there was a video
from one of post Malone's most more
recent concerts where a lot of people
are worried that he has a drug problem
and these are the clips that's what I
mean I'm two years away from this but
yeah go
[Music]
there's no boy here no go then keep
going up until about a rock start doing
rock star [ __ ] here well does anyone
seem do drugs as far as I know he only
drinks beer and smoke cigarettes that's
why he came out and said I have a friend
who's very close to him and I thought
the same thing ago dude
how many drugs is used dude only drinks
but life smokes cigarettes
I give you my word yeah that's why he is
well known for but a lot of people are
concerned over a lot of different
artists overdosing that when they saw
him acting this way on his concerts they
were worried that he was on drugs he
actually had to come out and during the
following concert after this one he
actually came out and said that he's not
on drugs and he had his like on his like
on tour photographer come out and also
say like nobody on the tour does drugs
all he does with the terrible tattoos on
his fastest Pachi well that's what the
kids do face tattoos yeah he's so
talented
yeah oh why because he wrote songs for
cut youth before he's a writer for Kanye
West Oh Papa he writes all original
songs his song with Ozzy Osbourne and he
on the guitar he's ridiculous asked me
how you learn to play guitar myself that
but Guitar Hero oh he has video him on
guitar you ripping it up and he goes I
was really good on there I'd post it and
I was like dude I gotta learn the real
thing Wow I have something yeah so then
he learned the real guitar it's a real
musician all people just have that he's
so talented
he's stupid talented he's a writer or
really so he started as a songwriter for
Kanye West
he sold songs for taught a bunch of guys
look it up chin but he wrote songs sold
to Kanye I forget who else but I bought
like big big name artists start off as a
rider Wow he came to LA with his buddy
cuz his buddy was a youtuber and was
like dude they're all from Texas that I
dude we're gonna go to LA try and see if
we make it because they were doing
YouTube videos so he goes I don't have
any money can't come with you Angus but
can you help me out you make him after
you do because I had no money so every
day would scrounge around look for
quarters and change to buy cigarettes
and Bud Light and then
start with his buddies would do like the
twitch stream like you and he'd be in
the back playing and like [ __ ] with
people and then he got on there playing
guitar hero and then wrote his own album
called white Iverson it was like I'm
just gonna release it everyone goes dude
don't really sit wait yes I don't have
any money I'm dead broke I need to get
this out there put it out there he goes
ten times platinum oh my god and now
he's postman oh my god was that good
he's a savant holy [ __ ] he's very good
he's got a great voice
he's he's just he's just very very
unique yeah yeah Wow very very gifted
musically songs written by post Malone's
is that did that show it no I liked him
about tattoos yeah you know what the
tattoo says always tired yeah so yeah
but up now now the carnivore died
wouldn't hurt him a little weight on
yeah it's that beer man drinking those
empty calories damn but I'll skip I
don't give a flying [ __ ] it to you he
gives you [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah maybe it
depends everybody cares about how they
look especially I got like this well
yeah I don't know if he cares physically
like about his like physique some guys
don't give me fine [ __ ] good-looking guy
there though I like the way it looks
with that long hair right there with a
cigarette in his mouth usually here's a
cool style yeah it but you know it's
just for him they be tough some of it
like he is his style is very cool he
looks cool when he wears like jackets
and like his tattoos yeah he's a
musician he's creative artist yeah yeah
didn't need the tattoos can just be to
help I wish she would did you Styles
cool I love the style now my big s
where's that they're heroes ago Jesus
you're gay let's limb there used to be
thin but then you start doing you know
all that bear I've got those empty
calories huh tattoo hands yeah that's a
lot that's a lot of commitment not a
work when you see my back ripple and I
pull myself up like a champ
like shampoo 30 times fast while talking
to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a guess it's a gift it's a gift